it's deadline day for the Biden
administration's ultimatum to Texas
governor Greg Abbot they're demanding
the state allow federal agents to remove
Razer wire border barriers but Texas is
responding come and take it setting up a
very high stakes battle in court one
Governor Abbott insists Texas can win
hello everyone this is outnumbered I'm
Emily compano and joining me today fox
and friends first co-host Karly shimkus
Fox News contributor Lisa Booth Fox News
contributor and president of American
Spirit Enterprises Tammy Bruce and Fox
News contributor attorney and retired
NYPD inspector Paul Morrow now the GOP
governors of 25 States half of the Union
have now voiced their support for Texas
and Governor Abbott here are two of
those governors on the fauler focus last
hour this is a a no-brainer every state
now is a border state when you have Joe
Biden's Democratic opponent saying this
is uh outrageous and out of control of
the Border when you have Democratic
Mayors across the country that are
saying this is outrageous and
something's got to be done and the
Republican Governors we have been
standing in solidarity for you know well
over a year couple years now on the
disaster of the Border I've been down
there four times myself the White House
and Joe Biden just obviously doesn't get
it or they don't care there is no word
to describe this except Invasion uh the
open border policy the Biden
Administration is making every state a
border state as Governor Kemp said and
it's time for the uh Administration to
step up and do their job that's why it
was not a question about whether we were
going to stand uh with Governor Abbott
in protecting the southern
border meanwhile Democrats are calling
for President Biden to escalate the
developing standoff and seize control of
the Texas National Guard here's the
White House's response on that some
Democrats are saying the president needs
to federalize uh the Texas National
Guard so look something that could
happen I mean look I'll say this you
know the border patrol agents are now as
you said allowed to cut through the wire
because of what the Supreme Court has
laid out it's it's unfortunate that we
had to go there it's unfortunate that
there is a governor in Texas governor
Abbott who has politicized this issue of
what's happening on the border and it's
not making people's lives safer it's
actually making it harder for law
enforcement at the at the border to do
their
job Paula her talking points fall so
flat in the face of all those risking
their lives to secure the border and
when she talks about what's unfortunate
it's not unfortunate it is tragic and
what is tragic is the Biden
administration's lack of enforcement of
policies that created this crisis that
now Texas is just trying to protect
herself and the question remains the
Biden Administration has ignored all of
those border states and therefore now
all 50 states who have become border
states why are they trying to
collaborate now and it's really I tell
you it's it's become a parody I could
listen to her all day you know because
it's uh it's look they have got
themselves into a situation that they
really wish they were not in they own
this now and it's really a lot simpler
than they're conveying when they came in
they undid remain in Mexico out of spite
it was just an anti-trump measure and
that's it now they own it but as easy as
it was to undo remain in Mexico it is
just as easy to put it back in place
it's essentially an executive order
Biden only needs a pen and a phone to to
use Obama's line and they really are
complicating this for political purposes
because they're stuck every place has
become every state is now a border state
as you say they know they going into an
election year having federalizing this
the Texas National Guard you know what
that's going to look like just optically
for the voting people voting uh the
electorate in this country it's just the
kind of thing they don't want leading
into an election it's a stressor on our
institutions that it's going to be
really palpable and unfortunately they
have painted themselves into this corner
they own it what Abbott should be doing
as they take down this razor wire
obviously he's putting it back up but he
should be taking migrants why just New
York bust them to DC bust them to the
front of scotus bust them to swing
States put them in Atlanta so that these
people when they go to vote see what
they're getting and Lisa let's talk
about this you know half the country or
more is behind Texas's decision and
their actions not just legally as legal
experts have weighed in and judges and
the like but also a lot of other
Governors and Attorneys General so for
example South Dakota governor Christine
n she says I'm so proud of what Texas is
doing we are right there with them we'll
do everything we can to make sure this
Invasion stops what message does that
send to this Administration well I mean
it sends a message that the states are
asserting their rights right I mean I
made this argument on this show a year
ago that I wanted conservative states to
band together in a freedom caucus type
way to fight against a federal
government that's become too centralized
too big and that has failed in you know
its interest to Americans to protecting
Americans and that's what's happened I
mean you have a federal government that
has failed to protect us from an evasion
failed to enforce existing federal law
and then now is trying to undermine
Texas's right uh to fulfill its
constitutional duty to defend its
borders and to defend its sovereignty
and so that's where we are now but I
I've been wrestling with this broader
concept which I I think this all begs
the question of are we still a country
right because the the Constitution is
supposed to be the supreme law of the
land and how many Americans have any
reverence for it anymore how many
lawmakers have any reverence for the
Constitution anymore we're supposed to
have Sovereign borders we're supposed to
be a Sovereign Nation we no longer
defend them we're supposed to be a
nation of laws and we no longer so you
know what is holding America together
and and are we still even a country and
why does Action seem to only happen at a
minimum rhetoric right around elections
yeah well because timing and politics is
everything uh in this country and
throughout the world and I and speaking
of Elections I I think that throughout
the course of this year this issue is
only going to get worse you're going to
see more illegal immigration because of
the presidential election you know the
word is going to get out there's a
presidential election in the United
States if you want to go the policies
could could change go now so that's
something to look out for the other
thing I was thinking I've been thinking
about is why this is the number one
issue in New Hampshire and Iowa and it's
because it's one of those issues that
has so many tentacles that touches upon
other things if you are already worried
about National Security you look at the
southern border and go well now I feel a
whole lot worse think about the economy
how many millions of people are
scrimping and saving only to see their
hard earned money and then tax dollars
go to free bees for other people so
illegal immigration is one of those
issues that magnifies other issues in
this country and then there's this
what's going on between the state the
state and the federal government text
this Governor Greg Abbott and President
Biden I I don't know what's going to
happen in that Supreme Court battle if
it gets to that level again there are
real legal issues and concerns over his
definition of the word Invasion and the
Supreme Court has already rolled against
him once but could you imagine if he
didn't try and he just let Texas get
smacked in the face with this issue no
responsible Governor would ever do that
so even though he's maybe fighting a
losing battle legally he still has to
try I love that Carly so much as former
president of the Federalist Society
Federalism is there for a reason the
states have to stand up for themselves
to Lisa's Point earlier when the federal
government becomes bloated and
bureaucratic and and it's beyond
Behemoth size that is what squishes the
American people in the states Tammy I
really wanted to get your thoughts on
this because this is an interesting
development and it speaks to the
election impact and the fact that all
Americans are impacted equally so we
have RFK Jr standing with Governor
Abbott tweeting this he says Texas is
Right Biden's fail failure to secure the
Border leave States no choice but to
take matters into their own hands as
president he says I will end this
humanitarian crisis once and for all I
will secure the border and destroy the
business model of the drug cartels a
country Without Borders is not a country
at all what say you well you and this is
good news you know for Democrats you can
be a Democrat you understand because
this affects the safety of your family
it affects whether or not your child's
going to die of a drug overdose it's
about National Security if you have a uh
young person who's thinking about
joining the military whether or not you
really want to encourage them to do that
I I wish Robert Kennedy was less of a
liberal nut on every other issue um but
it this is good because when it when
push comes to shove we are all in this
boat together right and I think that
that's what for the American people what
they see the White House not
acknowledging that they're
underestimated the American people are
we're treated like hamsters it's as
though the America average American
citizen doesn't exist or they don't
count because Biden is now in a position
where they say that he's acknowledged
it's a crisis and they're trying to fix
it and and yet then they're going to go
down and cut razor wire to make it
easier for people to get through to have
more of an incentive at a most dangerous
crossing point this is not the entire
border it's not the legal points of
Entry it's a dangerous point of coming
over and so now he's going to be faced
with that I love seeing the Republican
band together that is a change that
states can do something we're just not
all going to be victims that's a key
reminder for the American people for the
voters that you are not helpless in this
situation and that's why I think it's
going to really rings a bell with people
hey everyone I'm Emily compano catch me
and my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaylee
mcki on outnumbered every weekday at
12:00 p.m. Eastern or set your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights